so we're gonna begin our discussion
today with a question that is for each
one of you and that question is what
three resources would you recommend to
high school or university students who
would like to pursue a career in your
field so I'm just gonna speak about this
practically and I'll speak about
becoming a clinical psychologist and
that's associated in some ways with
becoming a professor so that'll do the
trick so you have to take a bachelor's
degree likely in a science oriented
field I would recommend especially if
you're going to university now to stick
fairly close to the disciplines that
have at least one foot in science that
would include psychology generally
although there are more scientific
subdomains of psychology and less
scientific subdomains if if the people
that you are being educated by have to
know something about the brain or about
biology it tends to discipline them
quite nicely and so that keeps them from
falling too far astray into the more
cult-like
elements of the modern University you
have to do exceptionally well in your
last two years of your undergraduate
degree to have a chance to become a
clinical psychologist you need a a
average with really without exception
and you have to do extremely well on
your Graduate Record exam which is a
kind of a general purpose entrance exam
so it's it's very competitive and and
then so that's the practical issue and
then there's another practical thing to
consider which is that if you want to
become a clinical psychologist you don't
get to pick the school you're going to
go to unless you are unbelievably well
qualified as an undergraduate you have
to apply if you want to get in to a
clinical psychology program you have to
apply to like 30 including places you
think you'd never go because you can
always say no if someone says do you
want to come and you have a couple of
choices well lucky you and if you only
have one choice well and it's not a
school that you would normally consider
it might be a lot better than nothing
especially because you educate yourself
in
many regards and then having said that
so those are the practical issues I
would say read the great clinicians
there's a very large number of them that
were stretched across the 20th century
I've put a number of books of that sort
on the reading list on my website and
you can't go wrong by reading Freud and
by reading Jung and Adler and Carl
Rogers and Abraham Maslow and the people
who established clinical psychology as a
discipline and the behaviorists as well
who have very many extraordinarily
intelligent things to say about the way
that human beings and animals as well
learn so and then the other thing I
would say is if you're gonna be a
clinical psychologist you know what do
you need to be like temperamental II and
you have to be interested in people you
know you and you have to be interested
enough to really listen to them because
a huge part of what you do as a clinical
therapist and this is also true if
you're a physician by the way that data
on this is quite clear is that you
listen to people and by doing so you
might ask them questions when you can't
understand what they're telling you but
a lot of what you're doing as a listener
is helping people sort themselves out
you know like you just can't believe how
many people have no one to talk to and
so and people most people think by
talking it's actually really hard to
think because to think properly you have
to be like three people in your own head
because you have to have an argument you
know and all of those different little
avatars of yourself have to be well
armed and ready to have a battle and you
have to be able to tolerate that and
it's it's a really difficult technical
exercise it's not like everyone knows
how to do it and just because something
pops into your mind doesn't mean you're
thinking it's the testing of what pops
into your mind that's the thinking and
so the way that people do that when they
don't think which is really almost all
of the time is that they talk to someone
else and then the thinking is watching
how the other person reacts to what
they're saying you know with the lift of
the eyebrows or maybe you know the
person dozes off which is not generally
a good sign or you know you're getting
feedback from the other person
constantly about what you're saying and
and and you also listen to yourself and
that can clue you in a lot because
you'll end up saying if someone's
listening to you you
end up saying things that you don't
necessarily agree with and you won't
even notice that till you put them out
on the table and so the other thing if
you want to be a clinician is like
there's nothing bit and if you want to
be a good partner to someone for that
matter there was absolutely nothing
better that you can do than listen so
that would be my two cents I suppose
well I would say if you you want to
become an artist I would say don't it's
really not a good idea there are too
many artists then we don't need anymore
so that's the first thing so if after
I've said that you still really want to
be an artist I would say for any art you
make I would say draw that's learned to
draw draw from draw from observation you
know copy the masters and then learn to
draw from the structures from the inner
structures learn proportion learn about
how to to to lay things out there in
composition all those things that's
really and that you can do you can do
that on your own you can do that you can
take life drawing workshops you can do
all that how that kind of all that kind
of thing the second thing I would say is
to make sure you have people around you
that are ruthless and that will not try
to make you feel good that's one of the
things like I really did I really
disliked art school for the kind of
postmodern ideology that was taught
there but one of the things that you do
learn even today in an art school is
that you learn to be criticized and you
learn you learn to have people around
you that are looking at your work and
are just going to go at it with a
hacksaw and you have to take it because
when you're making art for yourself and
you're making art for your family and
it's all nice and cozy that's all good
but if you if you're if you really have
the idea of doing it professionally you
you have to have people around you that
aren't there to make you feel good about
yourself and they're gonna rip your
things apart so I think that that's
really important and in terms I would
say of being a liturgical artist because
that's what I do like becoming an
iconographer that's really the hardest
part because ideally you would have to
find a teacher and there aren't really
that many teachers around and so if you
want to become an iconography first of
all I would say again don't because
there are too many action ah it's the
same thing but if you really want to do
it I would say you need to you need to
find a teacher if you can't find a
teacher
luckily online now we have there are
people like I was lucky I didn't have a
teacher and I when I started to learn to
carve I told you that story yesterday I
was lucky to have some really good icon
Carver's that were willing to be
ruthless with me and just look at my
things and just hack at it and and take
it down so that I would become better
and so I know that I cannot refer x'
they love iconography and so if they see
someone who is really dedicated who's
putting in the work you know who's doing
the drawings who's going who's going
full at it they will be happy to give
you criticisms of your work and if they
see that and to kind of help you along
because artists are actually really
excited to see other people that that
can that are coming and that are doing
great things so though that would be my
basic advice
[Music]
dr. Peterson this next questions for you
is deconstructionism and gender Theory
the final phase of the iconoclasm of
heresy I don't know if I understand that
question well enough to answer to tell
you the truth because I don't know
enough about the iconoclasm heresy so
can you define it okay so the iconoclast
khana clastic controversy was a moment
in the in the time of the church where
they began to doubt whether or not it
was possible to represent Christ in an
image and the idea of course is going
back to the Old Testament that this idea
of a transcendent God which you can't
represent and the the final argument
given by the church is that no indeed
when God becomes man when God takes an
image then we represent him as man in
that image and it's become the this
notion that God manifests himself you
know through image and through and in
the world is becoming that it has become
the cornerstone of Christian tradition
you know and kind of like the final like
that when they said that they called it
the last ecumenical council it's like
the last moment where the whole church
agreed on something was that the images
were going to be part of the church was
like a seal that said yes God does
manifest himself in the world and those
things can be encountered and engaged
with and so I think that the person
asking that question is asking whether
or not this the the post-modernism is a
continuation of this idea of iconoclasm
where forms where structures where
images cannot contain sparks of divinity
can't contain actual meaning so how do
you think that's related to the idea of
Gender Studies let's say well the
agender GBI so answer the grounds like
it so far are you doing a pretty good
job
the problem the problem with the new
gender theory the it has it does indeed
have to do with with iconoclastic
controversy because the idea is that
there is no there is no relationship
between let's say and there is no
necessary relationship between the say
the idea of male and the manifestation
of masculinity and so it's they're
divided and and so you could either see
that either as an iconoclast as a
continuation of the iconoclastic
controversy which in a way is all is
really a pursuing of the Gnostic heresy
which is to believe that what's really
important is what's these abstract
things ideas of their and the world
there is no there is no direct
connection between the two and so with
that thinking you can say well
masculinity is just an idea and so if
you want to be masculine you can there
is no necessary connection between let's
say your body and masculinity they're
separate ok and so the the people who
are promoting this theory describe
people who believe the scientists for
example who believe in in a direct
connection between that is biological
essentially and they regard that as a
form of intellectual fascism right right
ok so that's that's that's that's how
that's reflected in the secular world
yeah and post-modernism has has that as
well it's the idea that they're all
forms are equal like any form will do
right and so you can put it you can make
a painting of the in most insane thing
and it's equal to you know an icon of
Christ because there is no necessary
hierarchy there's no necessary
relationship in form between the the
ideas and them and their manifestation
whereas the the liturgical idea and the
the really the traditional Christian
idea is that liturgy is that Christian
life is the union of those two things
together you know and that appears as
the cross it it doesn't mean it doesn't
it appears only as this glorious golden
thing it does but it also appears as a
diamond so it's not it there is
there's an aspect which is true in that
when the thing when when when the divine
appears in the world it's it it can
appear as sacrifice so that the form can
be sacrificed than to be resurrected in
a glorious form whatever that means but
it there is a relationship I think
between iconoclasm let's say and and and
the post-modernism it's like it's mostly
a neo Gnosticism I think it's the
probably the better way to see it is
that this idea that that we're spirits
you know and our bodies don't matter and
we can kind of make our bodies fit
whatever imaginary spirit that we have
but that's not the image of the person
in the Christian and the Christian
tradition the idea of the person is
really this union of heaven and earth
and to into into a being yeah so it's
just a bit of comment on that it's like
one of the things that that have has I
would say astounded me to some degree
about the idea of the divinity of the
body is that that's and that seems to be
an idea that's very hard for modern
materialists who maybe have a spiritual
bent to accept you know they tend to
think of the soul as something that's
completely disembodied and the problem
with that is that it it doesn't address
the problem precisely because the
problem it or it makes the body into a
problem that has to be solved without
having a body and that's actually not
much of a solution it's actually a
denial of the utility or the divinity of
the body and so that's another danger
and separating the spiritual too much
from them or the ideon too much from its
embodiment it's the it's an escape from
the embodiment ER and escape from
incarnation it's something like that and
that might be equivalent to the denial
of biological reality something like
that so anyways definitely Jonathan
could answer that question better so so
so in that answer there both of you
discussed the concept of post-modernism
and so any of you can speak on this
topic but would you say that there is
any hope for post-modernism well there's
something right about it what's correct
is that there is a very large number of
ways of interpreting
a small set of phenomena and it's
actually in some ways a testament to the
possibility that's embodied even in a
determinant actuality like I mean this
is a water bottle but it could be a
rather ineffectual weapon you know like
it there's all sorts of possibility in
every situation and the postmodernists
made that diagnosis correctly in some
sense and it was discovered at the same
time in all sorts of other fields so I
mean the people who were first building
artificial intelligence systems who were
influenced by the behaviorists more or
less thought of the world as as as we
see it made out of determinant objects
with defined borders that were actually
there in some real sense independent of
us and so they thought of figuring they
thought that figuring out how to act in
the world was going to be the difficult
problem for artificial intelligence but
what they learned very rapidly was that
the difficult problem was seeing the
world because the boundaries that are so
obvious to us are not so obvious out
there in the external world it's not you
know and Jonathan made an allusion to
that today when he talked about grouping
things to go to the gym that's like well
why are those things in your gym bag
well it's a category things that go in
my gym bag
what kind of category is that well it's
defined by embodied purpose and and this
is actually quite well understood and in
in cognitive psychology so for example
there's a guy named GERD gigerenzer
who's quite a quite a brilliant
psychologist and he talked about our
ability to generate categories on the
fly and his favorite example is things
to take out of your apartment when it's
on fire right and you know well you
think about the things you take out they
bear no objective similarity to one
another right
they're united by something like like
purpose and so um the so the post
anyways the post modernist claim is that
that there's a very wide variety of ways
to interpret the world and that turns
out to be exactly right in a very very
deep sense but where they go wrong and
completely and utterly wrong is to
assume then and Jonathan also alluded to
this that all the solutions to the
problem of perception are equally valid
and that's just that's just wrong
and the way they gerrymander that is
incensed by denying the reality of the
objective world because you know so
there's lots of ways of looking at this
situation but there are only a set
number of ways that will get me through
that door without causing conflict with
all of you you know like if I walk to
that door and I just pushed you all out
of the way or hit you then the
probability that that's one way of
getting out you know it really is and
it's one of the many ways I could get
out of here but the problem is is that
you would likely object to that and so
it's a perceptual possibility but
there's no way of instantiating that in
actuality and so here's the problem with
post-modernism and I think Jean Piaget
had this figured out a very long time
ago is that out of that infinite number
of possible perceptual out of that
infinite array of perceptual
possibilities you have to extract out
that tiny set of solutions that not only
fulfills your aim in the in the actual
world but fulfills it in the actual
world and the social world at the same
time in a way that doesn't interfere
with you doing it again in the future
and in a way that if you do it really
well that also facilitates what other
people are doing at the same time and
man that's a serious that's a serious
number of constraints right and it's
sort of akin to the god of the child
who's playing a sport as a good sport
who gets invited to play again and so
you have to organize your behavior as a
consequence of your perception so that
it actually not only lays itself out in
the world in the manner that you intend
and desire but so that it does it in a
manner that everyone else is happy with
and that propagates itself properly
across time as you play iterated games
and there's a very small number of
solutions to that problem and we even
know some of them so we talked a little
yesterday about dominance hierarchies
which was a term that I objected to but
let's call them hierarchies of
competence for the sake of for the sake
of further discussion I mean I mentioned
that hierarchies of that sort are at
least a third of a billion years old and
virtually ever
animal way even if they're not social
animals even even a social song birds
have hierarchies in the in the
distributed social community and the
reason for that is that there just
aren't that many solutions to the
problem of how to get along in the world
when other creatures are trying to do
the same thing and so the parts
postmodernists are correct in that they
make an allusion to the complexity of
the world they're correct and saying
well there's a very large number of ways
to interpret Shakespeare and how do you
know which one is right and slights like
a stupid question in some sense because
like it like it
interpretations of Shakespeare that get
you killed aren't practical they're that
there's there's a simple way of talking
about it
so they don't take into account the
constraint systems that are part and
parcel of being and and they gerrymander
that away with this intellectual sleight
of hand which is something like well the
objective world doesn't really exist
anyways in society is infinitely
malleable and you know it's like no
sorry that's just not right and so so I
don't think there's much much much hope
for it on that end because there it's
just that's wrong and we know it's wrong
so yeah yeah I just want to add
something about about post-modernism I
for myself I I have a lot of quite I
have more sympathy for both modernism
that maybe I show at first glance I
reading some of the postmodern authors
are what helped to shake my to shake the
certainty of modern absolutes let's say
and you know what's interesting to know
is that a lot of the postmoderns a lot
of those that it that created the the
the idea of poly semi which is this
notion that there's multiple
interpretations of text and that texts
say of multiple things you know who they
were actually reading medievalists they
were reading they were reading authors
that were interpreting traditional
Christian texts or traditional
rabbinical texts because in a
traditional world in in in the Middle
Ages let's say no one had a problem
with the fact that text had multiple
meanings it was just a given
everybody knew that the text had
multiple meanings everybody knew that
the Bible had multiple meanings that
that the myths had multiple meanings
that you know the the different
traditions and multiple meanings it was
not a problem the problem is when
there's no hierarchy and so the the the
the medieval Christians they would say
that texts have multiple meanings but
then they would immediately structure
those multiple meanings into a hierarchy
metaphysical meaning spiritual meaning
social meaning personal meaning and then
those would be lined up so you then so
then you see a structure and a text you
can apply it at different levels of
reality so what the postmoderns did is
they just took the poly semi and they
got rid of the hierarchy and then they
started to show that there are patterns
in the text which are not there at first
glance if you look into it these other
patterns emerge and it's often these
counter patterns because if you say
something you're always secretly saying
the opposite you have to there's no way
around that because to declare something
is to secretly declare its opposite as a
buffer if you want and that's what the
post monitors do they go into the text
and they find that line of opposite
those the string of things that show the
counter text and they bring it up and
they flip the world upside down and they
say well why don't we put the counter
text on top let's say and say they can
make text say the opposite of what they
there that we always have thought that
they would say and it's possible to do
that and it's actually sometimes it's
actually perfectly coherent but what
they're missing is exactly what Jordan
is saying is that the counter text is a
marginal thing and it's in a marginal
thing for a reason for all the reasons
that I that I talked about let's say
today or that I've talked in my other
talks about the margin has a function
and it has to be on the edges of our of
our perception if you put it in the
middle the world be his falls apart so
there's something valuable I actually I
read Jacques Derrida I read
a bit when I was in college and I
realized that if you read Jacques
Derrida you can actually just tap him
back and he flips back on his feet you
can do the same thing that he does to
the text you can do to him you can use
his arguments and you can just twist
them so that a traditional world comes
back into being that's really the post
post-modernism you can do that and
what's happening is what's happening
right now is exactly that what we talked
about yesterday this whole idea of these
gestures these gestures that are acting
as as a kind of double turn where the
clown's are bringing the world back on
their feet we're seeing it happen before
our very eyes so I would say everybody
pay attention it's gonna be a very
interesting time for the next few years
because you're going to see a lot of
things come back in at should even in a
traditional way you're gonna see it
happen and it's going to be these wild
wild people like Jordan it's gonna be
these outliers who who are going to act
as a yes it's the wheel of fate turns
upside down and then it comes back and
it's you know it's gonna have you really
see that with Milo you atlas I mean you
know like what what the hell is up with
him you know I mean he's he's he's he's
an impossible person fundamentally you
know there's a there's an article with
he did an interview for this super
liberal Catholic I don't even know I
don't know a lot about the Catholic
politics okay but he did an interview
with his extremely liberal Catholic
magazine and they thought they were
gonna get what they wanted from him
right they thought they were gonna get
exactly what they wanted for him so they
did this long interview and then they
didn't publish it because he's the whole
interview he criticizes homosexuality
because the whole interview and so they
just didn't publish it because he was
like wait how did that work anyway so
yeah who thought I was a joke this is
really a joke but I I am my constant
joke is that I never thought the end of
the world would be so funny
I hope you've noticed nobody wants a
postmodern surgeons in the varieties of
religious experience William James spoke
of the religious temperament do you see
any correlation between innate
temperament and personality and
religious experience oh yeah we've done
some studies on that so if you imagine
that a religious system has two elements
let's call it the dogmatic element and
mystical element the mystics are the
Liberals and the ones who are more
concerned with the dogmatic element are
the conservatives and and I'm not saying
that one of those is preferable to the
other by the way because one is about
structure and it's maintenance and the
other is about change and dynamism and
you need both of those things there
they're there they feed into one another
mutually and if you let the Mystics get
the upper hand then everything dissolves
into a chaotic confusion and if you let
the dogmatist get the upper hand then
everything stagnates and turns into it
took into a tyranny so you know you need
to have the dynamic going and it's the
same in the political realm essentially
and I think what the the basic
personality difference is that the
liberal types so the people who are
liberal or lean to the left are high in
trait openness which is the proclivity
for divergent thinking and lateral
thinking and creativity essentially and
low in trait conscientiousness and the
conservative types are low in openness
and high in conscientiousness and so
well so what that there's a bunch of
practical implications of that one is
that it's the liberal types who start
businesses but it's the conservative
types who run them and so that's that's
you know it doesn't take much thinking
to figure out that that's a pretty good
deal you know the the entrepreneurial
types are definitely creative types and
they tend to flip from project to
project like they're interested in
what's novel and what's and what's
radical and what's transformative but
they're not interested in in tracking
things and ordering them and putting
them forward in this sequence and doing
their duty that's that's that's for more
conservative types of people and so and
the
liberals when they when you look at what
they regard as you know lots of liberal
types to say well I'm not religious but
I'm spiritual and really what they mean
is that well I have a hard time with
with adhering to tradition and I'm not
necessarily very disciplined but I
certainly have the capacity to
experience aw let's say or aesthetic
aesthetic experience and those things
you really need to know that those
things are deeply grounded in
temperament it's important to know that
because you tend to think that the
differences between say liberals and
conservatives are matters of opinion but
they're they're not they're deeper than
that by a lot they're they're really
differences in the manner in which the
world presents itself to them because
the very template that that governs
their perceptions is not the same and
it's deep these are very very deep
differences they're they're neurological
differences they're characterological
differences and and there's also they're
all those different personalities have
their niches as well so they're
necessary and part of the way that well
I know here's another way of looking at
it is that liberals don't like borders
and conservatives do and it's not just
borders between states or countries its
borders period the Liberals think geez
we shouldn't have borders between things
because that delimits them and which
does and and the conservatives say no no
no we need to have borders between
things because that keeps them properly
separate and distinct it's like well the
problem is is that both of those are
right and and it depends on the
situation to some degree and I'm not our
argument for moral relativity at all I'm
saying that in order to determine which
of those principles applies in the
particular situation that obtains in the
moment you have to have a dialogue
between the different temperamental
types to come up with a consensus that
hopefully does something like
approximate current reality and that's
really what a democratic system does
right that that's why I'm such an
advocate for free speech it's like we
have different viewpoints in different
religious viewpoints for that matter and
the way that we stay oriented as a
consequence of those genuine differences
is by communicating with one another
constantly because the alternative is
you swing too far in one direction or
the other or you start to go at
each other's throats and like unless
that's what you want that's not a very
good idea so speaking of the importance
of communicating with each other one of
the ways that obviously one does that is
through art and mr. Paseo that is your
specialty so this next question is is
for you as well as dr. Peterson or
others is contemporary art including
commercial art such as Disney Nintendo
or DC Comics a route out of nihilism for
today's Lost Boys well that's that's one
of the bets that I'm that I started
making especially with these these
YouTube videos that I've been doing is
that there's an interesting thing that's
happened like let's say since the 90s
maybe more explicitly started happening
before that but there's been a
deliberate attempt to include within
popular culture religious and
mythological motifs and it's really
deliberate it comes to Joseph Campbell a
lot but then you know other other ideas
and and it's really it's a practical
thing like it's for them it's a
practical thing they realize oh there
are these stories these patterns that
underlie our experience if we put them
in the stories people will come see them
we make a lot of money everybody's happy
right so it's it's not like they're
wanting to create illumine beans let's
say but it there there is this there is
this growing tendency to put those in
there and sometimes it appears in dark
and twisted ways it's I'm not trying to
defend what's there but what it's done
and I'm and I'm seeing that it's
happening is that it's opened up a space
that maybe wasn't there a little while
ago it's opened up a space of perception
that wasn't there and I think it is
possible to enter into that space show
people I hope show people those patterns
and then say okay does that get you
excited and a lot of people are like
yeah that's exciting and then you say
well that's nothing compared to what's
like in the Bible like it's it's it's
like it's dust on the on I mean it
the patterns are there and they're real
and they're and they're powerful but
like if you really want to see how
beautiful the world is if you really
want to see how amazing structures can
exist in human society it's like look at
look at look at look here instead and so
I think I think so and we're seeing it
it's really weird like this gamergate
thing it's really weird to see what's
happening
it's as if these these men It was as if
gaming was the last hiding place for men
you know there's nothing left in society
except for when they're because you're
not allowed to express their aggressive
behavior not allowed to be aggressive in
any way not allowed there are no
warriors we don't celebrate warriors we
don't celebrate honor and courage and
all those things we but only in video
games we still do and so it's like this
last refuge and then all of a sudden
with this weird gamergate thing there's
this whole group of gamers that all of a
sudden became social commentators and
are on YouTube you know they're not even
talking about gaming anymore
they're basically engaging the world and
talking about politics and ending and a
little group of those you know and a
part of those they discover Jordan and
now they're saying oh and there's also
this spiritual aspect to this it's not
just politics it's like they're moving
and moving and so yeah it's weird
I wouldn't have predicted it but I can
see it happening that's for sure yeah oh
that's good that's so the next question
is for dr. Patrick with the follow-up
for a doctor Bissonnette Petrie how
would a scientist talk about grace
erupting into a person's life that's
where dr. Patrick thank you the same as
anyone else except that the arenas where
it pops up are going to be different and
there's plenty of examples within the
scientific history and we don't know it
you see I mentioned this morning very
briefly that both Einstein and Kepler
and the guy in in in this city who
picked up the double reading frame they
all insisted they didn't work that out
they saw it that gift is there
in my own way I can point to that sort
of thing as well
science is not this cold predictive
thing that it's presented to be there's
a huge amount of intuition involved in
it I mean at any given time there are
hundreds of thousands of experiments you
could do the art form of science is to
do the right experiment at the right
time I say to Christians we've got to
start on that one pray about what you do
next that's worth praying about and it
also changes the way that you look at
things grace appears on my CV there's
one paper that I mean I'm 20 years out
from publishing I get emails every week
about work I did 20 years ago it's very
very rare in silence and one of them all
had my mother's name on it it saved a
lot of lives over the years and I don't
understand it to this day
I I went to Jamaica to try and
understand malnourished children and I'd
been fortunate to invent a new technique
so that I could get at cells and look at
the behavior one of the major transport
systems a sodium pump and because the
problem with the malnourished child is
not that it's sick but that it is alive
it ought to be dead all our standards
that char Lord have died months ago but
it's not it's alive so the major
question to begin with was how is that
done and when you looked at the amount
there there about 30 percent more
efficient than any other child of their
age but they purchased that efficiency
at a price and they're only really if
you think of yourself as a bloated cell
they're really only two systems that
could give that amount of energy savings
one is protein synthesis and the other
is membrane transport and I happened to
be fortunate again at membrane transport
at that point very much a surrogate but
nevertheless a real one so I had a very
simple hypothesis that it would be
turned down and after Barrett a year or
so I managed to get enough studies done
that it was worth looking at a datum
sure enough I was right
but when I looked at the data and I
still plotted data by hand people lose a
lot by sticking the data in a computer
and having a printout things happen in
your head when you do it by hand so when
you're doing something new it's good to
do it by hand and there were about five
outliers now there were well over five
standard deviations from the others and
the standard scientific procedures just
to dump them something went wrong down
Aurora T's it doesn't matter anyway
but my mother imprinted on my backside
when I was quite small quite a hard
addiction to truth-telling and I didn't
know any reason why I should have got a
different result so at least I had to
look at them now by this time we got to
stage we were we were saving almost
every child that we got through the
first 12 hours but there were a little
group of about 5% that died later when
we tried to feed them and we had no idea
why they died very quickly and we didn't
we had no clue lo and behold when I went
and got out the notes of these outliers
they were the children who died later
and to cut a long story short that led
to an intuition about how you might
treat that and it worked
I would never most people would never
have looked at that data I only looked
at it because of all that history behind
me and that's the way it works things go
on for years and years and years and
then somebody realizes I mean we first
had microscopic looks at bacteria in the
late 1600s early 1700s and yet we didn't
get to microbes in medicine until 1860
why didn't we spend 150 years not doing
anything about it because we were locked
in a mindset that medicine was about
letting blood out and making you puke
off it's quit you know that was it and
doctors made money so why would they
change it that's the way it is the world
doesn't work in this cold predictive way
there's all sorts of things going on
that you need to be willing to be humble
about
new little you learn a particularly in
Africa its Thomason start on it so
doctor Bissonnette Petrie the follow-up
to that question about grace for you is
is grace something like the right brain
being granted re-entry after a prolonged
exile
oh yeah probably it's one way to look at
it grace is is the is the way in which
heaven and earth are are come together
and that's through the Divine Spirit of
God and that the Divine Spirit of God
dwells within the human person and it's
like ripples that we have no idea how
how the presence of the the divine
within our being is affecting other
people I mean we do know that that we do
know that that the presence of the
divine is transforming us into virtues
we can we can we can look at that and we
can see that we reflect on that we can
look at other people and we can see that
they're moving towards virtues and then
we have to say that well where did these
virtues come from well the person was
working very hard on themselves and they
were but there's another level of it and
that is that we have an infinite effect
upon upon other people and and the
presence of the divine has an enormous
effect for the good the opposite is true
also and I don't think we have really
any idea just how much of an effect that
presence of the divine has within us I
know that it was explained to me by by
one priest that that said that you know
we well we know that we in it from the
Catholic faith we are a combination of
audience spirit and there they're there
they're just so United that they're the
only split at the time of death and then
we we believe of course that the spirit
then then lives on but then they're not
split so so we have we have an enormous
effect on each other spirit
and that's what we can't really measure
but we do have an enormous effect upon
each other's spirit that we can't that
we don't even really perceive but when
you're in the presence of someone who is
really really good really holy who has
the presence of the Divine Spirit within
the minute and really manifesting itself
interior ly you don't know that but you
feel you feel peaceful you feel good in
their presence you feel safe you feel
you just feel good and and we perceive
that and the opposite is true too and
we're in the presence of somebody who is
who was really very angry and hostile we
feel that too so we know that we're
having an effect upon each other and and
and we don't really even know how to
describe it I mean some of the modern
psychiatrists are talking about you know
this reverb to reverberate 'iv energy
that's going back and forth between
people because they know there's
something that's going on we don't
really know how to put it into words but
but I would I would say that that when
the human person is really infused with
the presence of the Holy Spirit of God
then there is it that's grace and then
that grace pours forth through that
person to other people so I'm gonna try
to make it answer to that
that's very concrete but that
nonetheless serves the purpose so as
we've discussed just a bit ago there's a
very large number of ways of looking at
any set of phenomena and so then the
question is well what determines what
you see and the answer is what you aim
at and this isn't a metaphor this is
exactly how perception works so for
example if I look at that door now my
eyes are moving back and forth very
rapidly otherwise I wouldn't be able to
see it all and most of what I see is
very low resolution so for example if
I'm looking at the door I can only see
you people over there as vague shapes
unless you move and then I can see a
little bit more clearly and you people
right in the way of me I can more or
less see your faces including
your noses but all you people over here
I can't get your facial features at all
and so my aim determines the manner in
which the world manifests itself to me
and there's almost nothing that you can
understand that's more important than
that and so and so now then you got to
think about that because then you got to
think about well what are you aiming at
exactly now imagine you're a scientist
and you're looking at a set of data and
the data can be handled in very many
ways and like statistics isn't this
process whereby you feed in a bunch of
numbers and you get out an answer like
that's not how statistics works it's
more like a set of surgical tools where
you're cutting a apart something
insanely complex and if you're very
fortunate you might find something
that's and so statistical analysis is
actually dependent on a very large
number of ethical decisions like maybe a
thousand difficult decisions are ten
thousand ethical decisions and how you
make those decisions determines in no
small part what answer is going to
reveal itself so for example let's say
you're really career oriented and you
have an experiment that you know you
really want to publish because it'll
move your career ahead and the doubt is
a bit sketchy and you have to make some
decisions about outliers that might be a
good example about which statistical
technique you're going to use or which
part of the story about the experiment
you're going to tell because you're not
going to tell the whole story because
you can't write a thousand pages you
have to condense a day and so it's kind
of a post-hoc story and and you try to
make that represent the truth but then
the question is what's the truth now if
you're this sort of scientists say that
has decided that the truth is going to
rule above all including your career
stains then you're gonna come up with
all different experiments and
interpretations than someone who's like
30% admixture of insane careerist and
20% narcissist and you know maybe 10%
truth seeker and and and though
everything is like that hey so then
imagine that you live inside a hierarchy
of values that determine your aim and
and you do that that's how it works
because you know if you if you stop a
kid at University and you say well why
are you in this class
well they'll say well I I need you know
they might say I'm interested in it but
they might say well I need this class
too
I need to why are you studying well I
need to get a good grade - and why do
you need a good grade well because if I
don't get a good grade then I won't get
my degree and well why do you want your
degree well I want my degree because I
need to have a job and then you ask them
well why do you have a job and you know
then they have some rationale about the
job and and you ask them why they
believe in that Roth snell and like
about four questions in they're annoyed
at you because they're out of answers
but the thing is is that every single
thing you do is nested within a
hierarchy of of morality and at the very
extremes of that hierarchy so the
highest ends you there's there's this
decision between good and evil is set in
essential essentially that it's part and
parcel of every decision you make
because the fundamental question to some
degree is something like are you aiming
at making the world a better place or
are you aiming at making the world a
worse place every decision you take is a
choice between good and evil in that
sense and so part of the way that you
might say that God's grace operates if
you want to be mechanistic about it is
that if you're oriented towards the
highest good the then the things that
come to you as your perceptions orient
themselves around your aim are going to
serve that purpose and that's actually
like there's not a single element of
that that's metaphorical that's actually
how your perceptions work and then your
motivations in your emotions line up
around that and so do your actions and
so it is the case that the the manner in
which the world presents itself to you
depends on your ethical aim that's how
it works and so if you're really trying
to make the world a better place let's
say and the more deeply that's the case
then the more likely it is that the
manner in which you might traverse that
pathway is going to reveal itself out of
the infinite number of possibilities
that are arrayed in front of you so it's
very very like we actually really
understand how this works and it's it's
not metaphorical it's not even some
sense it's not even spiritual it's just
it's just actually real and and maybe
that's the best of all possible worlds
when that's the case so you know here's
an example and then I'll be quiet about
this question
and say you're having an dispute with
your with your wife it's like what do
you want out of that dispute you want to
win well then she loses well then then
you have a loser on your hands and maybe
you are maybe you want to be married to
a loser maybe that's part of what you're
aiming out you know because then you get
to be the good person in the
relationship and she gets to be the bad
person and well then you can have all
the joys of martyrdom that's pretty
entertaining and you've got moral virtue
at your fingertips because if you defeat
her a hundred times in a row then she's
gonna be bitter and hate you and then
you can really play the martyr and be
the superior person and you know all of
that's going on when you have the
discussion and maybe what you want
instead is peace you know you actually
want peace and tranquility and so you
think well I'm gonna I'm gonna listen
because maybe I'm even gonna help her
make her argument against me just on the
off chance that she might be right
because actually what I want is peace
and and that determines the course of
the dispute and it determines whether
it's a battle for victory or a battle
for the solution of the problem so that
you can both move ahead in Union which
is what you're supposed to do and and
that's another example of how your
ethical aim determines the manner in
which the world reveals itself and
unfolds itself and none of this is
metaphor and none of this is none of
this is it's absolutely concrete reality
it's it's how it's how it works it's how
we perceive and well so there you know
the grace of God is manifest when you
aim at the highest possible good it's
like aiming at the cross on the church
that Jonathan talked about today you
have to be oriented all the time to
creating the sort of world that that you
would want to bring into being you have
to decide what sort of world that would
be and then everything falls into
alignment behind that either for good or
for evil and and follow-up coming I
should have done this before grace in a
slightly different way some years ago I
had a call from a professor in Minnesota
and he said I want you to write down
your face story to which I replied no I
don't do that and he said well I said
I'm not interested in a sentimental
project and then he made me explain he
said look you how soon do you teach and
I said never before fourth year why
would I he said you ought to I didn't
but the point of the matter is for you
who send your children your
grandchildren to university especially
in a research university they're not
going to meet a tenured professor in the
first two or three years in most cases
they'll be taught by people much lower
down the order and he said that means
they won't hear a positive comment about
Christianity in from their teacher from
the electon because if you declare
yourself to be a Christian in a Western
University you lower your chances of
getting tenure dramatically so he said
I'm trying to find tenured professors
who dump something people know about and
getting them to write their face stories
down and in the end I did and he
published a book with 22 professors in
it's called professors who believe I
think it's still in print published by
IVP I was worried about it but when I
got it I couldn't put it down
because it really was Grace ain't my
favorite one I forgotten his name of the
moment he was a biophysicist at
Princeton a geophysicist at Princeton
and he was a complete naturalist he he
worked hard at his work and he was a
scientist first second third and fourth
and he used to go in on Sunday morning
because that was the only time when
there weren't grudges students around to
Ricky's work but then he got the
Augustan syndrome you all know the end
of the first paragraph of the
confessions our hearts are restless
until they find that rest in be he had
the Restless heart he couldn't settle
down so he started going to Princeton
Chapel where there are a few vestiges of
liturgy remaining but enough for a smart
man to realize that there's something in
here that I don't know about and perhaps
I should and after a few weeks yeah a
woman was preaching on Sunday morning
and she said you guys out there in a
congregation you only respect the
opinion of other people with respect
your work probably only 10 people in the
world you care about but when it comes
to Christianity your knowledge is
roughly a kindergarten level and he was
smart enough to say my goodness she's
right I've never even read the Bible and
he said so I started to read it and he
doesn't tell you anymore because he
doesn't know what happened to him in a
way that he can describe and yet his
life was picked up and turned around and
faced in the opposite direction grace
like that happens and I love it it's the
one thing that really gets to me in this
world as I travel I have a very good
friend I had a very good friend he died
two three years back who said to me I
had meningitis so that you I had
meningitis so that he could become a
Christian amazing at the beginning of my
PhD I don't know nine months a year into
it I didn't have a single result nothing
was working I knew what I wanted to do
but it wasn't working and then I got
meningitis I'd done infectious diseases
the two previous years never got sick
there I was with a fairly serious
disease which would took me off work for
three months David moved in next door to
us in our little apartment in London and
he like me came from blue-collar
background and his dad had told him
David get out to earn some brass aged 15
but his teacher said David you smart
goat in high school he got an external
degree in mathematics in no time flat
less than three years from London
University he was working for roles that
apprentice electrician but they're a
good company they realized this wasn't
an apprentice electrician so they
promoted him shortly he was running that
he plucks analysis division for
rolls-royce in their nuclear engines
division with just an undergraduate
degree and of course Americans would
come and visit and they'd say this is
wonderful work dr. Dawson and he would
say mr. Dawson roles were embarrass they
said please get a PhD we'll play for it
and he said what the hell do I want a
PhD for I have to teach those guys what
to do and he wouldn't do it and
eventually I made him persuade him to do
one year master's course that the
Greenwich Naval College in nuclear
engineering so he agreed to do that
a year in London and he moved in next
door to us well I didn't know was that
this man for whom everything was Billy
touch was turning to gold was so sad
inside there was no meaning in his life
he could do anything he built his own
house he never bought a new car he got a
couple of scrap ones and built a new one
out of that he would the the the course
was boring him so he came home early
and we started playing chess in the
garden and you know you get headaches
after meningitis in one afternoon I had
to leave the chess I said David I've
gotta go in the lie-down
he said fine the next day when he came
back from Greenwich Naval College he
said have you got any more books like
that
I said oh that's where it went and I
don't know anybody else in the world who
was converted in two days by reading a
commentary on the book of habakkuk but
he did because it spoke to his soul he
came back and said if you got any more I
gave him loose his mere Christianity on
Sunday said can I come to church with
you and his life his perception of the
world was totally transformed he went
back to darby to his village he said
I've been there dozen years never
noticed that the kids didn't ever youth
group so he started one and he started
looking at his research group he said I
realised they got problems I could help
with that and I'd never done anything
about it so he started doing it before
long he was personnel director for the
whole of rolls-royce that's grace
that's how it works so if you're sending
a grandchild or a son or daughter to
university think about getting that book
and putting it on the shelf because
there's some 22 professors in there
covering a pretty good range including
one you might know tinder from Boston
College wonderful stuff
grace is real we need to bear witness
so for Jonathan just a moment ago in his
answer dr. Peterson used the analogy of
a pathway and that was an analogy that
you also used this morning and you
opened your lecture with it so the
question for you is about the other
analogy that you use and that was of a
pillar or of a point of reference to
orient yourself from and to find a sense
of direction you also mention how this
pillar is made through people binding
together and having a sense of community
how could one apply this idea to the
lifestyles of great thinkers and artists
like like Rilke and Nietzsche
who spent most of their time in solitude
and who even argue that being in
solitude is a key factor in making great
art well the thing about the thing about
that image of the pillar is that it's
the shape of everything that's that's
kind of how you have to see it it's the
shape of the cosmos it's the shape of a
community it's a shape of a family it's
the shape of a person okay and so in a
person has a center has a heart and now
I'm gonna use I'm gonna really use
Orthodox mystical language here so a
person has a heart and the idea in
traditional mysticism is to gather your
thoughts and to gather yourself and
enter into your heart and and when you
enter into your heart your heart is like
the the cup on the altar it's the same
thing that's there your heart is the
same thing as the cup on the altar and
once you gather yourself within yourself
into your heart then you become a locus
of divinity as much as it's possible for
a human being to be to be United to the
divine so that's why Christianity also
has a monastic tradition because the the
the the same reality that lets say a
normal Catholic or a normal Orthodox or
normal you know
Christian community would would
encounter the the anchorite will go
through that very you know in his cave
in on his own it's a part it is a
possibility but the idea is that even if
someone is alone and is doing that as I
mean I don't know I'm not by the way
it's not experienced this is all theory
I haven't done this but if you read the
father's and if you read the field of
Kelly and if you read the mystical
teachings what they tell you is that
once you enter into the heart you find
the whole universe is there and the
whole church is there as well and so
even though that monk is alone in their
cave and is and is you know spending
their whole day in meditation in prayer
once they enter into that divine spark
that is in the center of themselves they
find that they're in communion with the
entire universe and they are in
communion with the entire church at the
same time and so even for for the let's
say the the monastic approach of
solitude the the the trip is the same as
the community who moves in towards
communion so yeah I don't know about
about really and Nietzsche but that's at
least the monastic tradition I wanted to
make a comment on the pathway um kind of
tired today so I might give this quote
wrong with Christ said that he was the
way in that path and the way yes okay
the way is that is the part that I'm
particularly and no one comes to the
Father except through me
right okay yes yes good so when I use
this this idea of the path you know and
people are path taking creatures that
that's what we're like we're directional
creatures and so the question is like if
you're walking out of the door well why
are you walking out of the door and it
and I'm reassigning this idea of this
nested sequence of hierarchical values
like are you going what's your purpose
in going out through the door what are
you going to do out there and that
purpose can imbue like if the purpose is
the highest of purposes then that
purpose imbues everything you do with
divine significance and that's that's
actually correct I mean and I'm not like
I try not to be metaphysical about
things if I can if I
can possibly avoid it because it it adds
a level of complexity that that isn't
strictly necessary well I know but but
I'm not denying me that at all but it it
helps to make things simple as well you
know and it is the case that you have a
reason for walking out the door the
question is what's the reason and you
know you might say well it's a jumble of
reasons some positive or negative
well that's true cuz you're not this
this united thing that Jonathan was
talking about right I mean Carl Jung
certainly believed that the United human
psyche was roughly equivalent to the
self and that Christ was he called the
image of Christ and image of the self
the United self and so the idea that the
integrated human being is in some sense
in relationship with the ideal human
being is is a profound psychological
idea but like when you're walking out
the door the question is what path or
you want and that is actually the
question it's like you have mixed
motives let's say you know some of yous
dark and some of you is light it's like
well get rid of the darkness and then
when you walk out the door you're on the
path of light and then the question is
well what will happen to you if you're
on the path of light and the answer to
that is quite straightforward isn't that
is the best that can happen to you
whatever that is it it it might not be
easy it's that that it isn't going to be
easy easy and best aren't the same thing
somehow you know I mean you don't want
your child's life to be so easy that
they just lay on the couch and have a
machine drop grapes into their mouth
every thirty Seconds right it's that
isn't what you want you want something
like optimal challenge or heroic
struggle or or worthwhile engagement or
something like that it's not just the
absence of effort and and and you know
like a kind of neutral being it's it's a
call to adventure into into great things
and so you can have it so that
everything that you do partakes in that
to the degree that you're willing to
work to make that possible and then
everything that you do is imbued with
this sense of meaning because it's
related intelligibly to the highest of
goals you know and i always use the
often in this sort of discussion use the
example of Geppetto in the panel
movie you know when he makes Pinocchio
who's just a puppet whose strings are
manipulated by forces beyond his control
like that that's a person that's a human
being you know that's that's what we're
like and Geppetto who's a good father
prays he look he lifts his eyes up above
the horizon to the highest point that he
can conceive of and that's the star that
glimmers in the darkness right and it's
if you watch the movie carefully you
also see that that's the star that
signifies Pinocchio's birth and like the
meaning of that should be relatively
obvious you know and I mean it's a
nativity scene as clear as can possibly
be portrayed and Geppetto lifts his eyes
up above the daily concerns and aims at
the highest good at which that he can
conceive and then wishes for that for
his puppet then that's what starts the
transformative process that turns the
puppet into a real human being and
really that's what you're trying to do
in your life and with the people that
you love it's like okay well sit and
meditate and think okay well what's the
highest possible good that I could aim
at it's like well I'd like my life to be
in order and then I'd like it to be in
order so that everyone else's life is in
order maybe even the people that I that
I consider enemies maybe even their life
could be in order if I lived my life
properly and then and and you don't know
that that's not possible maybe you're
terrified that it is possible I think
that's the most fundamental terror that
that might be possible you know and then
maybe you're ashamed because you're not
living up to that and I would certainly
say that was the case so well so that
the pathway idea is an extraordinarily
profound idea and it's also one of the
things that statement of Christ's in the
New Testament is one of those things
that really strikes you you because you
think well what sort of creature would
say something like that it's such a
you're either completely out of your
mind to say something like you can't
even explain it that way and people try
you know they talk about Miss ionic
delusion or that sort of thing but it's
a it's a statement that has such an
unbelievably deep meaning that you can
hardly imagine that anyone say it and
and that's well you know you can take
that as evidence for whatever you think
it might be evidence for but it's it is
really an unbelievably Dee
truth it's it's it's something and one
more thing about that you see you might
say well what is that ideal path and how
is that symbolized by the idea of the
crucifixion and see what Christ did in
part is to accept the terrible burden of
being voluntarily and that's a really
hard thing to do because the the burden
of being is terrible tragedy and evil
those are terrible things and you can
decide that you're going to be
responsible for that right that's the
highest of all possible moral goods just
take on responsibility for suffering and
evil and I don't see how that's deniable
well I mean I can't see how you can
think of something that would be better
than that
like it's almost by definition nothing
can be better than taking responsibility
for that because what you're trying to
do is ameliorate suffering and reduce
evil well how is that not sort of
self-evident and then that can imbue
everything you do even this even the
simple job of taking a pathway and
you're always on a pathway so decide
where you're headed and and then you let
your life has the sort of meaning that
justifies it in some sense and that way
you can have your cake and eat it too
and so you know that's well that's a
pretty good deal if you can pull it off
so dr. Peterson you just went into depth
into the idea of the pathway and analogy
used by both you and mr. Peschel but the
other analogy the other image that has
been used was that of the pillar in his
lecture today and that was an image that
he just described as among other things
the center of the family and the family
is something that you have also provided
a commentary on over the years so the
next question is from a audience member
who says to dr. Peterson I have heard
you speak on the pathological family and
having the misfortune of being born into
such a structure my question is how does
the innocent child within me forgive my
family without excusing their evil and
at the same time avoid the seductive
temptation of the power that comes with
the innocent victim
card that many play well I think more
importantly in some sense than
forgiveness is a very complicated thing
because you just don't distribute that
randomly you know like there are
preconditions that are as far as I can
tell that have to be in place before you
can forgive someone if like if someone
has done something terrible to you and
like you don't want to carry that as a
burden any more than is necessary
because it just propagates it in your
own life right so so so there's a like a
psychological necessity to to forgive in
that you need to move beyond that right
but for someone to be forgiven they have
to I believe they have to have
recognized what it is that they've done
and then they have to repent which is to
say that they know what's wrong and then
that they have to change their actions
so that they won't do it again
because otherwise there isn't much
difference from forgiveness between
forgiveness and ignoring something
terrible that's continuing so but you do
have to lighten your own soul to some
degree I would say that your your goal
is to do what you can to sew together
the tattered fabric of being that you've
inherited so that you don't propagate
that forward in your own in your own
family and and that's that is definitely
something that people very frequently do
which is so here's a interesting
statistic so many people who abuse their
children were abused as children okay
and so you might think well there's a
causal pathway if you're abused as a
child then you abuse your children but
that's actually not how the statistic
works because if you take the total
population of people who were abused
bite you as children most of them do not
abuse their children so you know what I
mean you're looking at it from two
different perspectives if you take only
the abusive population then you can
trace it back to childhood abuse but if
you take the entire population who were
abused most of them dampen that down and
you can think about that mathematically
very easily because if it was any other
way you know let's say a person has a
couple has four children and abuses them
all and then all for those children have
four children and abuse them all and
then like in ten generation
everybody's beat to death all the time
and that isn't what happens what happens
is that it tends to dampen across time
which is nothing short of a miracle and
I've seen lots of people in my clinical
practice who had pretty miserable
childhoods you know where they're there
they were punished for their virtues
which is really the way to make someone
miserable if you don't punish someone
for doing something wrong that's amateur
stuff you punish them for doing
something right if you really want to
hurt them and so but they grew up and
they had children and they didn't carry
that forward you know they decided they
learned from what had happened to them
not to do it instead of learning to do
it and so now did I answer the question
I think what you do is you decide what
you want that's that's the other thing
is that you know you you do a decent
analysis of what's happened to you in
the costs and maybe you try to figure
out what the antecedent elements are so
that you can see it from your parents
perspective to the degree that that's
possible and then you related to some
way in some way and someone to talk to
that's rather wise can help you with
this you relate it to the suffering and
the evil in the world at large and try
not to take it as personally as you
might and then you do what you can to
move forward without carrying it and in
an any more any more burdensome way than
you absolutely have to and you know and
swear in some sense that you won't do
the same thing and that's about the best
you can do with this situation like that
so I'd like to add one thing to that we
say the Lord's Prayer frequently but we
ought to take a little bit more notice
of the verse that follows the Lord's
Prayer in the Sermon on the Mount which
is if you do not forgive you will not be
forgiven the basic sort I think is that
we are all fallen creatures and to that
degree we are all capable of any evil
that we can imagine it's only by the
grace of God that that is not the case
and so what Christ is doing in the
Sermon on the Mount as I understand it
is he's asking you to develop a way of
living day by day thinking your way
through a sequence which makes you not
just a mere believer but it is
and it's incredibly wise he says first
of all the first beatitude is you've got
to practice seeing the truth about your
own soul blessed are the poor in spirit
because if you get down on your knees
and say to God show me what I look like
to you I guarantee it will never be good
news at first sight we are all in
trouble but Jesus says the moment you
become that honest you are on the way to
the kingdom he says you've got it you
don't know it yet but he's knows it
because he is the truth so if you pursue
truth you get to him but that isn't
enough he says now you must repent
blessed all those that mourn because
they are the ones who are comforted
Lewis puts it in in the Screwtape and
not in mere christianity like this he
says God does not demand repentance of
you
repentance is simply a description of
what happens when you come to God coming
to God is repentance because he's holy
and that's when you receive comforts
what that does is it changes your
approach to life at another level which
is blessed are the meek the word that's
translated meek is used to describe a
horse that's been broken in and trained
to ride into battle you are meek when
you wake up in the morning and you
realize you are forgiven for no reason
except grace and the person who gave
that grace is going to ride you into
battle today if you let him isn't that
wonderful metaphor and it's so releasing
isn't it the horse doesn't have to have
any big plans for the day just to buy
this can take anything nasty that's been
done to you you put it through this
process and you come out the other end
it you you are now really caring about
the person live the heart
it's an astonishing thing because the
next thing that happens of course
because it's working you start hungry
and thirsting for righteousness which
Jordan basin is doing very well I mean
he can hardly open his mouth without
hungry and thirsting for righteousness
the promises is going to be satisfied
that's what that's what Jesus says in
this that makes you in turn the one that
we probably need in our society as much
as any particularly in
she said now blessed are the merciful
for they shall receive mercy this is if
you do not forgive you will not be
forgiven if you can't be merciful to
somebody else it's because you haven't
seen what you are really capable of so
if you're in trouble we're not being
able to forgive you've gotta go back to
the beginning that's the way it works
it's an iterative loop and I've got to
show you what's this hanging on to this
doing to my soul show me how I can
release myself be released from this and
that will happen and then you move on to
the next one which is blessed are the
pure in heart for they shall see God
which is Kierkegaard pretty beautifully
is - will one thing a life that is only
concerned with thy will be done it's
very hard to hit injure you
I mean people can't hurt you it's
amazing because the moment you they try
that sequence kicks in and you start
praying for them I've seen it happen
because the University is a very nasty
place and that's my response and it's
I'm praying silently of course but I've
watched people look and wonder what's
happening to them I know what's
happening and then you go on to the next
one which is you become a peacemaker
because academic Smith's go on for years
and sometimes it gets so bad they want
somebody to calm it down for a bit so it
has to be somebody who's transparent
that both sides trust and then they
persecute you afterwards nothing
seriously now well really but but that's
how it works
so whoever asked that question here's an
experiment for you to do read the Sermon
on the Mount every day for the next
month and work your way through that
sequence every day I think you'll be a
different person at the end of the month
I have one more comment about that I
guess um I was thinking there was images
running through my mind here during this
discussion and I remembered a trick that
my wife and I learned when we were
trying to figure out how to settle
disputes you know and if you're not
having a dispute with the person you're
living with you're not living with them
because you're different people and and
you face very complex situations and so
there has to be disputes because if
there isn't you're not communicating
right because life is very hard and
you're not the same and so and so then
the question is well what do you do
about a dispute and while you're tempted
to win as I said earlier especially when
you get angry because angry anger wants
to defeat you know especially if it's
not integrated properly but one of the
things we learned to do was to if we're
at loggerheads and we couldn't figure
out how to how to advance we separate
and go into different rooms and then the
rule was you had to go in there and like
I suppose it was a form of meditation
you had to sit there until you thought
of something stupid you did within the
last six months or so that increased the
probability that this idiotic fight
would occur and you know it's really
annoying I think it's a form of Prayer
because it's really annoying because
you're just not that right and you make
mistakes all the time and so if you sit
down and you think okay how am i stupid
it's like believe me you're gonna figure
out a whole bunch of ways that you're
stupid and one of them will rise up
above the rest and it'll say well you
know here's something wrong with you
that's making this more probable and
then you have to go tell the other
person what that is and they have to do
the same thing and then you know you're
both humbled by that I would say you
know because you're not arrogant enough
to think you deserve to win anymore you
think yeah well I'm I'm I'm an idiot and
and the other person says well hey I'm
also an idiot and then you think well
the hostility in the desire for victory
goes out of it and then you can talk
again and then so with regards to being
misused you know one of the ways also to
to get out of that in some sense
I'm not saying let's say not if it's
ongoing because that's a different story
but if it's in the past I mean it is
really useful
Solzhenitsyn when he was in the prison
camps in in in in Russia he was having a
pretty damn rough time there's no doubt
about that and I mean he was there
basically because of Stalin and Hitler
roughly speaking and so he had every
reason not to fit you know to feel that
he was victimized and and and in some
sense he was but what he learned in the
prison camp was that he had participated
in the process that had imprisoned him
he was a staunch communist at one point
in his life and he was an arrogant
intellectual and he
learned often from watching people who
had very deep religious convictions as
it turned out which he didn't have at
least at that time that that it was
possible to act honorably even under
very difficult conditions and that he
hadn't done that in many places and
times in his life and so he said he went
over his life with a fine-tooth comb and
tried to figure out everything that he
had done wrong by his own admission you
know not according to some other
person's moral standards but when he he
could remember through his life when he
decided to do something he knew to be
wrong and then he tried to do everything
he could to fix that in the moment
whatever that was you know he sort of
asked himself in some sense or maybe he
asked his higher self or well I don't
care how you how you think about it
precisely but then he tried to do
everything he could to rectify that in
the present and the consequence of that
was the writing of the Gulag Archipelago
which basically took an axe to the trunk
of the Soviet system so it was a pretty
big deal that he managed this but the
thing is is that if you can't really
concentrate too much on the evil that
other people do to you because there
isn't much that you can do about that in
some sense like you don't you're not in
control of them but what you are in
control of if you want to be is the evil
that you do to others and to yourself
and then you might say well why do you
just concentrate on that because you
could actually do something about that
and then what you find is that the more
you concentrate on that the stronger you
get and maybe if you get strong enough
then the things that happen to you that
weren't so good you understand them much
better and you can forgive them more and
they won't run off your back like water
off a duck's back and away you go and
that I mean the alternative is is misery
and resentment and and hostility and and
the desire for revenge and all of that
and that's just that's a kind of hell
and that's not unless that's what you
want well you know people want that
that's the thing you know and it's
something we can't forget is that people
do want that because they're angry and
they're very angry they're angry at
being and and and they're willing to
walk down a destructive pathway that
that's for sure and if you can't see
that about yourself then you're not
paying attention so
so our last question dealt with the
topic of the family and in dr.
Peterson's final answer he discussed an
example of something that he had learned
throughout his marriage marriage of
course being the sacramental basis and
foundation of the family the next
question is nowadays many people are
waiting longer to get married and have
kids do you think this is positive for
women as it allows them to develop more
of a sense of self apart from children
before committing themselves to
motherhood and this is for anybody but
as it is about womanhood perhaps we'll
begin with dr. Bissonnette Petrie well
there's lots of ways to look at that and
my current bias is that you know it's
it's not good for women and it has to do
with with what what is the individual
woman's goal and I believe that most
women have a very deep deep desire that
comes not from you know any conscious
part of themselves but very very deep to
be a mother
and so it's it's really an in the
current culture which which I mentioned
in my my talk yesterday that that the
prior prior to contraception there was a
very big pool of men and women and there
was one man to one woman and and you had
many choices and you were very likely to
meet up with a suitable partner and have
a very good marriage what happened after
contraception was that the pool of men
and women which had been one-on-one one
man one woman divided into what's called
a pleasure pool and and a marriage pool
so in the pleasure pool you know we all
know what that is you just are not
interested in really getting married
you're not interested in having children
you're interested in pleasure and and
and how many women how many men are in
that pleasure pool it turns out that
there's one woman to six men in the
marriage pool those who want to get
married there are six women to one man
no this has created a lot
difficulty for for women because as they
well how do they how do they meet and
and marry a suitable partner it's more
and more difficult so what we see is
that there are fewer and fewer marriages
and there are more and more divorces
because people are marrying people that
are not suitable to them now women have
tried to cope with this by investing in
their in their own capital and and and
by that we mean that they go to school
they become nurses they become doctors
they become lawyers they become you know
they're trying to invest in their
capital to make themselves more
interesting more busy and and because
they they feel motivated to do that and
of course our culture has encouraged
that immensely which is just fine but
then they end up finishing their
education and you know they're in there
they're 30 and it's very difficult to
find a suitable partner a man at that
point and then their biological clock is
ticking and are they going to be able to
have you know the best of both worlds a
career children and and and a marriage
and and and children and and I have
talked with a lot of women in medical
school now when I went to medical school
there was one woman in my class
besides myself it was just we were not
and in my my father had actually said to
me women should not be doctors you
should be a teacher to prepare yourself
for marriage and and children and and I
my mother who was not really happy as a
mother and their that's that influences
you well why would I want to be a mother
my mother's not happy being a mother so
so I took this other path of you know
really and I'd been encouraged to do
that because if you have a brain that
does well on tests then they encourage
you especially if if you're good in
science they want women to move forward
where this back in this you know in the
60s so so I you know I ended up going
into my career because that was the you
know that was the path that that um
unfortunately I was able to marry and
have children
and and do the whole thing but I came to
the point where I realized that there
was a deep deep longing inside of me to
have children and you know I was in I
was about 27 years old and I was still
in my training because training takes
forever so you know we went ahead and
and and had children and I tell you that
I have never experienced the wonder of
life until I had a baby I mean it was
like this is what I was created for and
I fell in love with that baby like I had
never loved any other creature in the
whole world and I thought why didn't I
know this why didn't somebody tell me
and it's one of those things that that
if you drove with the mother who isn't
really happy being a mother then you
just kind of think well gee that's kind
of the way it is but this is the most
wonderful experience of my entire life I
don't care about being a doctor anymore
I just want to stay home with this baby
and so I worked everything out because
if you're a psychiatrist when I went
into practice you were able to set your
own hours so I was able to work for 10
hours a weekend and then when they went
to school I worked longer so I was able
to work it all out together but I don't
think that women have that privilege you
have that have that many opportunities
to do that today just because the
practice of medicine has become so
industrialized that you can't be in a
private practice and you can't set your
own hours you have to work for an
institution that's going to tell you the
hours that you're going to work so so I
really am concerned about about the
current the current situation with women
and there are many many women in medical
school and when when this this is told
to them that there are you know six
women to one man in the marriage but
they'll go yeah and and you don't even
experienced this this is reality
but they've invested in their capital by
making you know by making something of
themselves and so I asked Jay I'm a
young psychiatrist who's in training a
young man
and I said well you know when when oh
yes okay one one thing before I get to
that so so a young woman who finished
her training in gerontology and has a
practice and is working as a physician
fell in love and she was really happy
and she was telling me all about this
through the email and so I saw her at a
conference in September and I said I
understand you're engaged in this is
wonderful
no we broke up and I said well what
happened and she said well you know he
was really a wonderful Catholic man but
he wanted me to stay home with the
children and I just couldn't possibly
stay home with the children and I felt
really sad for her because you know I
think that it's not I'm not the only
woman who says wow this is the most
wonderful experience of my life when you
have a baby I think men feel the same
way but how do you tell somebody that
before they have the experience and and
so basically I just you know have said
you really have to try to look at things
from it many many perspectives and and
and try to figure out what your goals
are and you know I just backed off and
and and and because she was really
adamant that she was doesn't the right
thing that she's made the decision not
to marry this wonderful man because he
wanted her to stay home with children
with the children and of course you
could see it from his perspective I mean
children are much much better if one or
the other of the parent you know is with
them so you know I think that the
culture has changed so much that that
you know I think it is really important
for women to take a look at what the
culture is dictating to them they don't
want to you know maybe they don't want
to stay in the pleasure plus your pool
they want to move into the marriage pool
and and women do move into that marriage
pool sooner than men
then how many choices are you going to
have and of course the younger you are
the more choices you do have so and then
if you want to have children you've got
to think about that in your biological
clock so does that answer your question
[Music]
I'll see something about that I guess
I'd I'm not going to give advice to
women
well because it isn't all that useful to
give advice to people period because
they have to figure out their own
pathway but I do think that one of our
one of the things I am not very happy
about in relationship to our culture is
the way that we think about children and
the way they're also represented and you
know my experience has been that like I
went out once I had kids it's like I
would rather be with my kids than with
any other people now you know you kind
of have to understand kids you know you
if you want to go out to a restaurant
with your wife and you have a
two-year-old it's like you can go out
through 45 minutes that's it because
that's about as long as the kid even if
they're very well behaved can manage it
so you got to kind of clue in and watch
and but it's wonderful to have kids
because one of the things they do for
you apart from the fact that they really
like you is that which is not a trivial
thing man you know it's a big deal to
have someone want you around that much I
mean they're really funny they're
ridiculously funny and and and comical
and amusing and they're always doing
crazy things and so that's their very
cloudy and so that's really fun and the
other thing that's really cool about
kids is that you know as you get older
and we know this neurologically even you
stop seeing the world a and what you do
is you see more and more of your memory
so like if I'm walking down the street
I'm 55 like I don't look at houses I
just have an icon of a house in my mind
I've seen like fifty thousand houses I
don't have to look at a house you know
and so I'm sort of walking down the
street and it's full of these icons that
are drawn from my memory and there's a
deadening that goes along with that
because you replace the rich reality of
what's in front of you with with the
simplified representation that's
functional and it's efficient and all
that it really is but it's not rich but
then when you have around a kid
especially a little kid well that just
changes because you can see through the
kids eyes and then you know all these
things that you take for granted get
revitalized it's like living with a
little little artist you know because
artists do that for you too they
revitalize your perceptions and and I
found being with little kids was just an
absolute pleasure and I mean you have to
have an
sense to discipline them properly you
know and and and and that's hard for
modern people because they're really
guilty about even about the idea of
discipline sounds like you know some
sort of Nazi tyrant with a big stick
it's like that isn't what discipline
isn't that at all it's trying to help
your children behave in a way that has
helps other people like them you know
which is an act of love that's for sure
but so I think we do a very bad job of
selling children to our children you
know because we say well your youth is
over and you know now you have to take
on this responsibility and all the fun
has gone out of your life and it's like
well you know your life just wasn't that
fun when you were single you know you
don't remember that exactly and and then
well what about all the joy that you
have with your family and like is there
something wrong with that is that not
like the central fact of life you know
when you have to have a hell of a career
before it's better than having a family
and maybe even then it doesn't it
doesn't work you know for me I'd had an
really I would say like it's a I've had
a career that would be as good a career
as you could hope for let's put it that
way
and still you know coming home to my
family was always a relief and and and
and and something extraordinarily
positive and then as I've got older now
I have a grandchild and as I've got
older the relative importance of my
family has just grown and grown and and
I think that's inevitable as you get
older and so I think we do a really bad
job especially in relationship to young
women because we teach them a pack of
lies about what the world is like and
and and we don't inform them for example
about the phenomena that you just
described which is you know someone
else's baby that's a baby but your baby
that's like that's like a whole new
human being that's like part of your
family and it's it's this extension of
this sort of magical relationship you
have with hardly anyone else in the
world and all of a sudden you have
another relationship like that it's like
this is real like the image of Mary and
the Christ child is a sacred image for a
reason right it's it's there for a
reason societies that don't honor that
die and we don't honor that and that's a
big mistake and it isn't a moral mistake
you know
exactly it's it's just a big mistake and
we need to figure out how to organize
our society so that women who want to
have kids can figure out how to do that
without working themselves to death on a
parallel career and taking care of kids
it's really a hard thing to do and this
is one of the things that I really
dislike about modern feminism is that
they don't the feminists don't ever seem
to me to work for Mother infants you
know they don't they're not oriented
towards that and that's a big problem
because that is what most women who have
any sense want they want other things as
well but you know it's a big it's a big
issue and and it would help if we do at
least stop lying about what children
would like so that would be a good start
and this is for the the two professors
to what extent is the educational system
kindergarten for graduate school the
cause of society's problems is hugely
responsible that's why I'm still working
and teaching every week at my age
twenty-five years ago six of us at
Ottawa you had been watching students
arrive at University with a faith and
depart with that one take it that faith
taken away by professors who were
outrageous ly unethical in what they did
and we didn't know what to do about it
so we started reading we read everything
we could find for about five years
starting with the Greeks and ending with
Alistair McIntosh it was the best
seminar ever went to no advertising we
counted I think it was 19 languages
around the table one day one one time
and there would be about 20 people there
every week we eat we were even
headhunted by the Chinese government 25
years ago because they knew that
corruption was a problem and not having
enough children who are properly
educated the teaching ethics to 23 year
olds is a total waste of time it's too
late because the problem is not ignorant
it's a problem of the will and the will
has got to be properly trained a lot
earlier we didn't know how to do it but
slowly it became clear to us that almost
all of your children don't know who they
are and they don't know their hero's
that they should know now to truncate it
a long argument I'll turn it to my
favorite way of teaching anyway as Jesus
would a story but a true one in the next
90 seconds I'm going to tell you the
story of a man whose name you should all
know raise your hand it'd be interesting
for me to watch when you recognize who
it is he was born in London to a very
poor family his father was a blacksmith
what education he had was in the church
where he would be two or three times a
week you were smart but by the time one
at the back so far by Italians in eleven
or so he was an apprentice bookbinder
fortunately he had it smart boss who
realized he was a smart boy said you can
read some of these books you know so
they started reading the books he was
binding another one goes up and he loved
the science so he started going to the
free public lectures at the Royal
Society in the Royal Institute
he took excellent notes which you still
have and by the time he was fifteen or
so he knew he did not want to spend his
life binding books what he wanted to be
was the lab tech who set up the
experiments to go with the talks at the
Royal Institute so he bound his
treasured notes beautifully and trusted
them to the post and sent them to the
president who fortunately was a good man
and he read these notes was impressed to
cut the story short he got the job in
due course and very shortly he became
indispensable the boss started taking
him around to meet the great scientists
of the day so all around the world they
knew there was a very smart young man in
London who'd never been to high school
eventually he became president of the
Royal Society in stitute he turned down
the Royal Society twice said he was too
busy
he was known to stop the Royal
Institute's committee meeting so that he
could get to his prayer meeting and only
two of you put your hand up to say you
know who he is
yes who is it that's right Michael
Faraday deeply committed Christian but
this is we need to know these things so
when you start teaching this as Jews go
away they're proud of our history we've
got not with nothing to be ashamed of
compared to everybody else we've got
everything to be proud of and to emulate
if we can I mean one of these people got
in common caperna just to take one
stream of learning Copernicus Galileo
Kepler Newton Boyle Faraday Clark
Maxwell Eddington every single one of
them believed seriously if you take the
17th century the Golden Age of science
and take the top 200 scientists only
three of them were skeptical the rest
all believed and 50% of them devoutly
there's no war between science and faith
we've lost our educational process
because we don't have enough motivation
we've reduced it to mere information
tears Elliot saw it coming he wrote in
courses from the rock in the 1930s where
is the wisdom we have lost in knowledge
where is the knowledge we've lost in
information I usually add my own couplet
information is a medical student useless
infant knowledge is a resident dangerous
what you want when you die is wisdom
that's a guy who knows they shouldn't be
fiddling with you too much at this stage
but we now
pride ourselves in our University of
having an information rich environment
it's wisdom we need so yeah education
has lost its way completely but what
we've been doing over the last 20 years
it works you talk to the ones that are
here raise your hands those of you you
see them they're back there they'll tell
you what it's like firsthand so that you
don't think I'm hyping it I'm not I'm
absolutely amazed at what can be done
and it's got to be done otherwise we've
lost
well I'm a practical person I don't
teach things that I don't think are
useful and that's not the same as
imparting facts because there's as the
post modernists point out there's an
infinite number of interpretable facts
and so it's necessary to help people
figure out how to apply the facts and to
what and I suppose to some degree that's
wisdom and one thing that I've learned
well over my entire teaching career
because I've always been teaching that
way but especially in the last year is
that there's an unbelievable hunger for
that
it's just absolutely beyond belief and
no wonder because it doesn't happen and
people don't have direction and they
don't even believe that direction is
possible which is worse than not having
direction right I mean that's about
enough but then to think that direction
is impossible that's that's death and
it's all it's wrong and so I don't know
why the humanities precisely have lost
their way I mean I'm a fan of
Nietzsche's ideas on that you know that
it is associated with the with the death
of God so to speak I think that's the
correct diagnosis and you know I've
spent 30 years I suppose delving into
deep stories trying to reestablish
something like a foundation I suppose
for me at least and and then I suppose
to people who are listening to me
thinking and well maybe the time has
come for us to work towards transferring
our institutions back in the direction
of wisdom and characterological
development I mean that's education
right education is the development of
character because character is what you
use in life and again that's not
moralistic hyperbole it's just the
barest statement of the most
self-evident fact life is difficult and
you better be awake and attentive and
tough and courageous and truthful and
forthright and articulate to manage it
properly
to stop it from turning into hell and
and that's the purpose of education is
to produce people who are like that and
it's a noble enterprise and the
universities have let it go in many ways
and I don't understand why exactly and
well hopefully something can be done
about it and it would be good for us to
all try to do something about it then
maybe then it'll happen so I think it
happened to some degree at this
conference so hooray for that so at this
conference we've certainly gotten a
picture how each one of you is trying to
use your skills to make the world a
better place with respect to that in
your efforts to do that to make the
world a better place could you give us a
brief snapshot of what's going to be
your next step perhaps starting with mr.
Page oh well I have to say I've been
taken in a hurricane world wind and it's
all his fault really I mean I this last
year since since since Jordan I met I
met Jordan in 2015 so before all of this
kind of happened all of what happened to
him and and since I we did this little
interview and it wasn't even related
supposed to be related to what was going
on with him we did this interview online
and then since then things have
strangely tumbled for me and so I am
just I am I in in one way it's like I'm
amazed and I'm excited and I'm exhausted
and I'm just just like okay what's the
neck what's the next thing and I just
keep going one step at a time so I
really have no idea where this is going
in terms of my own my own participation
in it all I know is that I have seen and
I've heard and I've read and people are
sending me mess
every few days and there's something
that's happening and there's people that
are changing and and it's I can't not do
it I mean I can't I have two of you are
else I'm going to regret it for the rest
of my life and so yeah that's oh it's
just I started these YouTube videos
because people kept writing me and
saying they wanted to hear me talk about
things so okay so let's do YouTube
videos and then people start asking me
to come speak and so okay let's just go
and speak and now next week for the
first time I've always been it's always
been in religious situations and out for
the next week for the first time it's
like a political group like a secular
political group who's asking me to come
talk to them okay what am I gonna tell
them I don't know I don't know idea so
it's just like one step at a time but
all I can say is I I feel like there's I
feel like there is something rising up
that there's that there's something and
young men in their 20s 30s up to maybe
40 like you said there is a group of
them that are waking up and starting to
ask the right questions and moving in
the right directions and and all I hope
for is that there's going to be a
sufficient mass of those so that when
things start getting really wacky
there'll be some anchor and that that
can that can hold the center and that
can that can give us hope for for
something better to come out of this so
that's all I can say
well so I've been trying to figure out
for a whole year what I'm doing and but
some things have become clearer as many
of you know or some of you at least I've
been doing a series of lectures on the
psychological significance of the
biblical stories and I'm gonna keep
doing that until I can't do it anymore
and by then maybe I'll get through
exodus or something so and I'm learning
a tremendous amount doing that and it's
stretching me stretching my intellectual
horizons constantly and having the
deadlines in place is very useful for
that and so there's something about that
it seems to be a fundamental import and
so I'm going to do that and then I have
a book coming out in January called
twelve rules for life and my publicist
says I have to tell you that it's
available on Amazon so you can go I was
supposed to bring out some Flyers but I
forgot that was so and so I'll likely be
going around talking about that I mean
that seems likely and I might do a tour
of American Universities next year I've
been talking to some people about that
and that might be ridiculously amusing
and entertaining and so I'm thinking
about that and then I talked about an
online university and that's a tougher
one that's a major-league project and
I'm not sure I'm up to it maybe if my
health has been somewhat shaky over the
last wall though it seems to be
improving if I can if that improves and
I have the normal levels of energy that
I have then I can probably manage that I
have talked to lots of people in Silicon
Valley already about how something like
that might be structured and I have a
plan sort of laid out in my mind that
I've talked about with a number of
people and so that would be really
exciting because I think that it might
be possible to give people a very
high-quality humanities education and
also teach them to write and also teach
them to speak online for very little
money and in a very efficient
and so that would be I mean oh I've
learned how powerful the online video
technology is right it's a convert akin
or uh who invented the gutenberg it's a
gutenberg revolution it's a second
gutenberg revolution and we certainly
aren't taking advantage of the
technology to the degree that will be
possible so that would be really
something exciting to do and so and then
as Jonathan pointed out you know when
when things change around you in a
tumultuous way and in a chaotic way
which is certainly being the condition
of my life for the last year you also
just sort of keep up with what happens
day to day and people write me and they
ask me to do this and that and I try to
figure out what I should be doing and
then I go do it and I I do pay a lot of
attention to each day and I guess it's a
way of managing this and so I'm gonna
continue to do that and my wife helps me
there she's here with me Tammy and she
helps me very much with that and so it's
useful for everyone to know that but
I guess what I'm doing in part and this
is with regards to mostly to young man
by the apparent by the by the by all
appearances is to fight against this
pervasive cynicism and nihilism that's
an anti masculine spirit that's invaded
our culture which i think is will kill
us
it's a terrible thing and you know I one
of the things that's been very
gratifying about what's been happening
recently is that wherever I go young man
in particular come up and save it you
know they were their lives were a mess
and they were living a chaotic lifestyle
and a desperate and and useless all of
those things and that they've figured
out that that's not right and that
there's better things to do and they're
doing it and to go out that's so great
to come out to places and have people
come up and tell you that it's just like
you couldn't ask for anything better
than that
that's just absolutely amazing and so
I'll try to make sure more of that
happens because that that's a really
good thing and you know how yeah like I
said you can't ask for anything better
than that so I'm trying to figure out
how to do that most effectively so
[Applause]
thank you all for sharing your
experiences with us ladies and gentlemen
please join me in thanking the panel for
their answers
so this was an edited version of the
question and answer period given at the
North West Catholic family education
conference last October in 2017 I edited
the question and answers based mostly on
on the questions that were asked of a
Jordan Peterson and I because I know my
viewers that's what they're mostly
interested in but I'm also going to post
the full question and answers I'll put a
link to that at the end of the video and
also in the links the full discussion
lasts about three hours and there's a
lot of more interesting stuff in there
for those who are interested so for
those of my listeners and viewers who
are a Catholic and Protestant I wish you
a Happy Easter and for all my Orthodox
friends I wish you a blessed holy week
and I wanted to post some things on
Easter sadly I'm not getting able to get
to it I've have too many things going on
at the same time but hopefully I'll be
posting some interesting stuff that will
discuss the resurrection in the next few
weeks
also my movie analysis coming as soon as
I can get it done and so please share
this on social media and we'll see you
soon